nasa originally aimed to put people on
mars by the end of the 1980s
yet here we are 40 years later with
little to no progress in terms of a
crude mars mission
from nasa this apparent lack of progress
from nasa
is precisely why elon musk entered the
space industry in 2002
by sending a colony of mice to mars he
hoped to reinvigorate public interest in
space
and hopefully get nasa to do something
but he too quickly realized how tricky
mars really is
as his ambitious goals slipped from 2010
all the way to 2026 today
don't get me wrong here spacex is making
outstanding progress with starship
and it does look like they will be the
first to get people to mars
but what's a more realistic time frame
for a crude mars mission from spacex
well starting off let's take a look at
the most apparent challenge in
conducting a mars mission
which is the rocket itself spacex has
been testing a variety of starship
prototypes over the past several months
but development is still only in the
very early stages
for instance spacex recently completed
their first successful landing after
high altitude flight with sn10 which was
unreal at the same time though this
was only an altitude of 10 kilometers
the international boundary for space
is defined by the karman line which is
100 kilometers in space
so starship needs to fly 10 times the
distance just to reach space
which means that starship will have to
fly at significantly higher velocities
taking a look at the sn10 high altitude
test you'll see that the final engine
cuts off at about t plus 420.
if we assume that this is the apogee of
the 10 kilometer flight
this means that the average velocity of
sn10 during its descent is about 138
kilometers per hour
we may have seen a peak of about 250
but i don't think sn10 was traveling
faster than that during any portion of
its ascent
to put that in perspective the escape
velocity or the speed needed to get to
orbit is 40
270 kilometers per hour that's 161 times
the approximate max speed of sn10
now getting the extra power to reach
these speeds isn't too terribly
difficult
in theory you can just go ahead and slap
on a booster and dozens of more engines
as we learned with the falcon heavy
though executing this is much more
difficult
in 2011 spacex hoped that they could
simply strap together three falcon 9
boosters and call it a day
but this ended up taking them seven
years
considering this i suspect that
developing a starship booster with 35
raptor engines
won't be a walk in the park either
anyways
once they get past the challenge of
reaching such velocities we have a
handful of new concerns
first of all there's a challenge of
slowing down the super heavy booster and
starship from those speeds
and landing them we all know how
difficult it was to land a starship
after a 10 kilometer flight
imagine a starship skydiving from orbit
at tens of thousands of kilometers per
hour
and then trying to belly flop land aside
from nailing the landing
spacex will have to ensure that starship
is capable of handling the extreme
temperatures during re-entry
nasa estimates that re-entering crew
vehicles experience temperatures of up
to 3 400 degrees fahrenheit
or 1900 degrees celsius speaking of
extreme temperatures
starship and its engines will also have
to withstand extreme pressures
over the past couple of starship tests
we often saw engines fail during the
flight
this issue only becomes more likely at
high temperatures and pressures
considering all of this and the fact
that it took seven years to develop the
falcon heavy
i think developing starship into a fully
reusable launch vehicle by 2025
would itself be an outstanding
achievement keep in mind that we don't
even have a fully reusable rocket
at this point in time much less one that
can carry 100 metric tons
into orbit given that spacex didn't
really focus on starship development
till summer of 2020
such a time frame would mean that spacex
took starship from basically nothing
to an insanely powerful fully reusable
launch vehicle within four and a half
years
this would not only be extremely useful
for starlink but
spacex would also be able to really put
starship to the test with the dozens of
starling launches in the second half of
this decade
and in the meantime they can transition
into the next stage of starship
development which would be actually
getting to mars
the first challenge that comes to mind
when transitioning from an orbital
launch vehicle to an interplanetary
launch vehicle
is fuel to combat this spacex plans to
refill starship in space
this would be accomplished by launching
one starship that actually contains a
payload
followed by another starship that is
just filled with fuel in space
the two starships will connect and the
one with the payload will be refueled
and launched to mars
meanwhile the fuel starship will return
to earth again
this is simple in theory but likely a
lot more difficult in practice
once the payload starship is fueled
though the journey to mars is quite easy
starship can simply use the velocity
built up to leave the earth to cruise to
mars
however after starship gets to mars we
have a massive challenge which is
landing the starship safely
landing on earth itself is extremely
difficult but mars is on a completely
different level
for starters the martian atmosphere is
100 times thinner than that of the earth
on the bright side this means that
starship won't have to enter nearly as
high temperatures when entering mars
however starship will have to do most of
the work of slowing down
by itself and as for the belly flop
maneuver
i'm not so sure how well this will work
in such a thin atmospheric environment
maybe starship will belly flop at a
higher altitude to give engines more
time to slow down the vertical velocity
it will no doubt have to be much more
precise than on earth
another challenge when it comes to
landing on mars is a terrain on which
starship will land
there aren't any pavel any sites on mars
yet so starship will have to land on a
rocky surface
considering all of these major
challenges and actually getting to and
landing on mars
i think it's very possible that spacex
spends the second half of this decade
just trying to successfully land on mars
keep in mind that the window for
launching to mars is only open once
every 26 months
so spacex only has two maybe three
windows within the latter half of the
2020s
in the meantime this would be a perfect
opportunity to complete the dear moon
project
and potentially land on the moon this
also gives them plenty of time to set up
starlink and get that to a point where
it is actually profitable
anyways if spacex is able to
successfully land on mars by 2030
they can transition to trying to return
to earth safely and
the first step in returning to earth is
of course launching from mars
fortunately since the martian atmosphere
is so thin spacex expects that starship
should be able to launch from mars
without a booster
this solves a massive problem of not
having a booster available
but there's still the issue of fuel
currently the plan is to make rocket
fuel on mars using the ice on the
surface
and the carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
but the thing is
this requires humans to actually be
there the plan is to send two cargo
emissions with materials required to
build a propellant production plant
followed by two food missions their
crews are supposed to set up the
production plant after reaching mars
and then use a field produced to return
to earth this is obviously
extremely risky as astronauts are
basically screwed if anything goes wrong
in the entire process and to make things
worse
there's no way of actually testing the
equipment on mars before the astronauts
get there but let's say the entire fuel
production process
goes well even then we still have
several other concerns such as the
rocket tipping over
mars regularly experiences dust storms
that come along with extremely fast
winds
in fact speeds up to 113 kilometers per
hour have been regularly recorded by
probes and rovers sent to mars
and when starship is simply chilling on
a rocky surface with no support
structures
this is not the most assuring of
scenarios even if starship doesn't tip
over during the storm
it's very possible that debris from the
storm damages starship
which would be a nightmare considering
these significant dangers
spacex would ideally complete several
round trips to mars before they send any
astronauts
i'm sure they've already thought of this
and it's likely simply not possible with
current technology
however in that case i think it would be
best if spacex simply weighed this and
astronauts to mars
until they figure out a more robust exit
system from mars
maybe spacex could figure out a way to
launch from mars without refueling
after all it's just one landing and one
takeoff
moreover the gravitational force on mars
is less than half of the earth's
gravitational force
not to mention the extremely thin
atmosphere so it's definitely possible
and it will happen sooner or later
another solution would be designing
robots that were able to produce rocket
fuel
on mars by themselves this way they can
test the entire system before risking
human lives
if spacex does end up choosing one of
these safer alternatives
we'll probably see them testing the
given solution throughout the 2030s
i mean this is the standard falcon 9 for
instance was tested dozens upon dozens
of times before it was used to get bob
and doug to the iss
in the end taking all of this into
account a more realistic time frame for
spacex getting people to mars
is 2040. if spacex does decide to go
ahead with the more risky plan of
getting astronauts to produce fuel on
mars to return home
it's possible that we see crude mars
missions in the first half of the 2030s
but i think it's quite unlikely that we
see crude mars missions any time before
that
on the other end of the spectrum it's
very possible that we don't see a crude
mars mission until 2050
but let's hope that it doesn't take any
longer than that
also just for the record i'd be ecstatic
to get completely destroyed by elon musk
and see spacex put people on mars in
anyways when do you guys think spacex
will reach mars comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys are hoping
that we get to more sooner
rather than later and of course consider
joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
you